want to thank everyone who donated food  during our founders day celebration on  friday yeah you helped us collect  thousands of food items for serving our  kids so your donation is going to turn  into weekend food packs for more than 30  schools this fall it will help feed kids  who might otherwise go hungry on  weekends  also some channel 8 employees  volunteered creating personal hygiene  kits for women at project maryland  these items are often overlooked when it  comes to donations the group strives to  give women access to hygiene products  they need with dignity and we did even  more another organization we helped  called horses for heroes it's a  non-profit ranch using equine therapy to  help first responders and veterans they  got 20 different horses up there working  with folks who are going through dark  times and man they do great work